a hug with draymond green his former
teammate who did not play tonight with a
foot injury
all brooklyn 125-99 and after the game
charles went deep with kevin durant
you know kevin uh that was talk about
you coming back for the playoffs last
year so
you really just been working on your
game trying to get back your timing and
conditioning really
to be honest correct yeah
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
i have no idea jeremy you know kevin
uh i was talking about you coming back
for the playoffs last year so
you really just been working on your
game trying to get back your timing and
conditioning really
to be honest correct yeah
[Laughter]
i've never seen anybody give you just a
one-word answer man
what's up hey man i don't care y'all
know the dog put that picture in a chuck
face i don't get sensitive about these
guys y'all know how i feel
man face again yo man i had a serious
announcement to make it y'all keep
screwing around
no you don't want to get jeremy just
show me a picture of chuck's favorite
thank you what's your serious
announcement okay y'all know i partnered
with fanduel
yes yeah oh i'm gonna make my first bet
on fanduel
you're gonna make a better series enough
yeah what is it
uh my man upstairs got me the odds who's
god
no no god gave you the odds
jeremy
oh that guy oh that guy okay the
producer upstairs okay
what you're about to do huh is this
legal what you're about to do yeah
okay so i'm authorizing my agent
mark it's gonna be my i'm honored to
work with fanduel this is my first bet
oh my gosh i want a hundred thousand
dollars get out of here hundred thousand
dollar back i want a hundred thousand
dollars
on the portland trail blazers to win the
west
get that done tomorrow hundred thousand
dollars on the portland trailblazers
to make it to the finals i told you this
is the only guy
to win the window is to make it to the
nba finals yes they are going to win the
west
yes listen shaq and if i win would win
2.8 million 2.8 million yeah
i want to bet right now he's the only
guy in the history of
endorsements that's going to give every
dollar back to the person
he's the only guy don't go alone
hello the fanduel guys in their meeting
were like yes that's like we had not
agreed no they probably set the plane
for you like they do in vegas
like that i want to make that bet
official
a hundred thousand get you 2.8 2.8
i'm just gonna put a dollar put that on
the board
yeah for me
50 for me 50 for you and we split the
profits what is the uh
i don't trust them that much paul
latrobe give me your reasoning
kenny i think with the addition of a
healthy zach collins you know i love
zach collins
i think uh rodney i forget his last name
from duke
dandruff rodney hood